foreign
Kelly wants to know what do you do when
you're purging unwanted items in clutter
but family members are doing the
opposite oh yes well let's talk about
this it to me it seems like a simple
solution you just give them the things
you're purging if they're doing the
opposite what a perfect yin and yang
right I did this when I first started
simplify I went up to Ryan's house of
about 70 neckties I didn't tell them
about the minimalism thing yet and he's
like oh wow you're getting rid of all
these neckties
drape the neckties they were head
scarves ascots
he was using them as tourniquets yes
oh man I'll never forget all those ties
anyway did you feel betrayed when you
found out like the next week how much
you're free with less no to be honest he
gave me all those ties and like it
wasn't but a month I mean whether you
know I knew about minimalism or Not by
the time that month had passed but like
I had like basically taken five or ten
of them and then donated the rest but
yeah yeah and you actually got some
value from some of them yeah I think
that's the lesson here just because
you're getting rid of something
that is not bringing any value to your
life at all anymore it's in the way it
has turned into clutter for you those
neckties I was getting rid of were
clutter for me but they weren't clutter
for Ryan at least five of them weren't
right and so
I think it's important to realize that
well conflicting desires your desire is
different from your family's desire that
is not a sign of moral failure not on
your part and not on their part either
right if the other person wants to amass
things collect things and they say no
I'm a maximalist I want more things in
my life that's not a moral failure on
their part it's merely a
preference yeah TK I loved what you said
when we were at the Sunday Symposium
last month uh the October one we got our
final one of the year coming up uh
November 27th Sunday symposium.com
there's still a few free tickets left
but
you uh we're talking to this gal I think
her name was Heather the first gal who
asked a question and she was like really
upset like she was getting teary-eyed
you remember this rhyme oh yeah yeah she
was super upset because she's like I was
supposed to bring my boyfriend here but
he uh he didn't come he's trying to
decide whether or not he still wants to
be in the relationship and they're at
the event we're talking about being
Wiggly versus being rigid and how
everyone is a little bit rigid
everyone's a little bit Wiggly but some
people are more wiggle Ryan's more
Wiggly than me I'm more rigid than him
it's not an indictment that's not a bad
thing either being more rigid is not a
moral failure but if you realize that
you're not getting the outcomes you want
from too much rigidity then it behooves
you to be Wiggly and vice versa if
you're so Wiggly you're not getting
anything done that you want to get done
it behooves you to have some more
structure some more rigidity in your
life and the thing that she was talking
about there is like I want to be I want
to be more Wiggly but then she was
saying but there's so many as I asked
for an example what are some of the
things that you're rigid with she's like
well like for example I want the toilet
seat to be down
and I'm like okay uh she said no I mean
like all the way down because studies
show and I said let me cut you off there
if you're starting a conversation
where you're asking someone if they'd be
willing to help you you don't ever want
to start the conversation with studies
show studies show why you should help me
yeah
Ryan the data says that I'm right it's
not a great way to start the
conversation and I loved TK's
perspective on this conversation he
basically came in and said Hey listen
Heather you're
preference is merely your preference you
can go into this and say hey it's my
preference to have a toilet seat down
that doesn't require a single study it
doesn't require anything that's peer
reviewed by the way we appeal to
Authority all the time the studies say
or oh this is peer-reviewed like that's
a good thing right I was once at the zoo
and I saw an orangutan show his poop in
his hand to a bunch of other orangutans
that's peer reviewed
laughs
but that's what we're doing quite often
we're appealing to Authority right look
at my crap my peer-reviewed crap and I'm
gonna hurl this crap at you now in order
to get my way but if you simply show up
and say hey this is my preference it's
my preference Kelly to live with less it
is my preference
to own fewer things it is my preference
to not indulge in consumerism it's my
preference to avoid the shopping mall
it's my preference to own fewer things
so I have less clutter in my house no
one can say that you're wrong because
it's merely your preference yeah yeah
and and there's something about giving
an argument for your opinion that makes
it sound like it's stronger but actually
signals a kind of weakness to other
people because what it signals is I am
psychologically dependent upon your
agreeing with me in order to feel
comfortable having this preference and
so when I just State a preference this
is what I want it's strong because you
can't argue with the preference you can
say well I don't share the same
preference but that's it but when I give
you the argument for it it's an
invitation to argue with me because it's
a way of saying this is what I want I
prefer the toilet seat down or up and in
addition to that here's some research
that says it would be superior for you
to want what I want or this is why
you're an idiot or why you're illogical
for not also wanting what I want and
that's going to stir up defensiveness
and make the other people want to
contend with you sometimes the strongest
way to put your preferences across is to
just State the preference and show that
you don't feel the need to justify it
you don't feel the need to apologize for
it right I do want to say something else
too with this question about
you're purging and other people aren't
it's really the same as any other
approach that you take to making your
life better what do you do if you're
trying to eat healthier and all of your
family members and friends are still
eating pizza three times a day you force
them to stop you throw it out
you guilt and shame them
there you go right or what if you are
starting to exercise more and all your
family and friends are still being couch
potatoes what if you're starting to turn
down the social media and the TV and
focus more on reading or getting out in
nature or bettering yourself and all of
your friends are still addicted to their
phones and addicted to TV what do you do
you keep exercising you keep working on
your eating you keep focusing on your
projects you keep going outside you keep
focusing on the thing you can control
which is your own personal development
and you let your life speak and you give
other people the space to decide if they
want to work on themselves when it is
time for them to do that but don't use
other people as your reason to stop
doing what's healthy for you other
people are always going to be moving in
directions that are different from yours
or opposite of yours and you're not
going to change them right you're not
going to preach at them and make them go
oh okay I want to get on your program
and do the thing that you do you just
got to give yourself the freedom and the
permission to pursue what makes you come
alive even when everybody else is doing
things that for you would make you feel
dead inside yeah yeah Kelly I totally
agree with what you're saying here at TK
I mean Kelly your preferences or your
preferences your family's preferences
are their preferences and there's no
reason why those two can't live side by
side with each other and and maybe you
know instead of having this um it sounds
like a bit of a combative context maybe
you know work towards having a
compassionate context like how how can
you show your family
um not just support but show them
compassion when it comes to their
preferences because ultimately whatever
their preferences are
to have a good relationship with others
um we do have to be supportive we do
have to show that compassion we do have
to respect their preferences so yeah
this isn't about getting your family to
change
um to me it sounds like how can you find
a different context to help your
preferences live side by side with your
your families did you enjoy this
Standalone patreon highlight if so you
can listen to full episodes of the
minimalists private podcasts available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free
[Music]